the other big events that took place
over the last 24 hours
is related to the word pandemic we've
been toying with the word pandemic and
the w-h-o has now declared kovat 19 a
global pandemic vaguely defined a
pandemic means it's a disease prevalent
over an entire country or the world
exactly when you cross the line from
outbreak to pandemic is a question but
the w-h-o now says we have more than
125,000 worldwide cases about 54,000 of
those cases are currently active this is
now it has spread outside of the virus's
origins in China over the last two weeks
the outside of China cases have
increased 13 fold the number of
countries in which it exists has tripled
and it is now a pandemic now in practice
what is this change it doesn't really
change that much to declare it a
pandemic it is certainly a signal to
countries to do whatever they would do
when a pandemic is declared countries
sometimes have protocols where when a
pandemic is declared globally they do
ABC a different countries have different
protocols and the w-h-o saying it's a
pandemic means roll out the pandemic
plan the specifics of it vary not every
country has a pandemic plan not every
country like the United States is
willing to actually be proactive and get
moving on things now there is some good
news and some bad news in all of this
the good news is China has this under
control
China still has many active cases
because they peaked at so many but each
day China is having around a thousand
people recover and they have somewhere
around 20 to 50 new cases that's a
drastic daily reduction and if things
continue that way
Italy is soon going to have more active
cases than China that's good for China
it's very bad for Italy another sort of
bullet point of good news in the midst
of a lot of bad news South Korea has
very successfully implemented mass
testing we suspected that the early
death rate that was cited of 3.4 may be
high it may be weighed waited
towards older often including men who
smoke in China smoking of course causing
a weakened respiratory system it seems
that the reason the death rate was so
high early in China and more so among
men is for cultural reasons more men
than women smoked in China and a lot of
those early cases were in older male
smokers the South Korea numbers the fact
that they are testing more and have a
death rate of only 0.78 something and
we're looking for you know bits and
pieces of something short of bad news
the other positive thing is that as of
yesterday there were 81 countries with
zero cases and 57 of the countries with
cases had fewer than 10 by the time you
listen to this segment that probably
will will have already changed there are
lots of countries not successfully
containing this the United States seems
to be one of them Trump and pence just
won't stop lying to us about test
availability about the risk of this
exploding about the constant endless
lying that they themselves are directing
others to do stop testing this that the
other thing it doesn't stop what am i
doing I mean listen I'm washing my hands
more often before I don't think I wash
my hands every time I got home now I do
I'm probably staying in a little more
when I go out I'm opting for places with
fewer people I'm not going to large
gatherings I'm not going to concerts or
sporting events I'm opting when I go to
a coffee shop for the smaller less
crowded one although I ended up this
week at one that is kind of a bigger
more college crowded one I have not
canceled travel yet I'm scheduled to
travel in 13 days I'm gonna continue
looking at the situation there it is
domestic travel I am staying away from
family and friends who are more
vulnerable either because of their age
or their health situation that's that's
what's going on for now let me know what
adjustments if any you are making on
Twitter at D Pakman make sure to follow
me there and we'll have more about this
coming up later on in the program one of
our sponsors is privacy calm they're
giving you $5 when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy
/ Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm / Pakman